it was a crisis that demanded decisive
government action but the reality we're
told was anything but in a scathing
report mps called the afghanistan
withdrawal a disaster that put lives at
risk and let down both afghan allies and
uk soldiers
i know how much effort
we put in i know
i know what it cost quite literally
so many of us
and so
to see it come to this
is really difficult
the then foreign secretary dominic raab
was on holiday when kabul fell as was
top foreign office official sir philip
barton who the committee say should now
resign their absence is cited as a key
failure along with the complete lack of
a plan for evacuating afghans who'd
supported british forces
imtiaz sharifi had worked as a
translator and was evacuated with his
wife and two daughters but he says that
was only because they queued for five
days at the airport without food and
water
eight months on they're still in a hotel
waiting for housing the five days were
the worst day of my life nobody knew
what to do
where to go whom to contact and where is
the eligibility criteria mps also tried
to uncover who was behind efforts to
evacuate staff and animals from the
charity now's ad run by former marine
pen farthing they suggest the
intervention to prioritize them came
from boris johnson himself an allegation
downing street denies but the committee
say multiple senior officials told them
otherwise this report is about as
damning as it could be identifying
failures of intelligence diplomacy
planning and preparation which it says
will damage uk interests for years to
come
the government insists lessons have been
learnt and that staff worked tirelessly
to evacuate more than 15 000 people but
it seems the consequences of operation
pitting are by no means over yet iva
bennett sky news